hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 130 something
139 of course yeah um yeah i did not uh
think to look up the number but yeah
139. so we were of course off
last week unavoidably as our producer
was uh
in ecuador in ecuador yeah and yeah not
just metaphorically he was actually
physically on the ground in ecuador yeah
um just back still um spiritually still
there a little bit psychologically
absolutely yes he's uh coming down from
the mountains
yeah yeah indeed um but here we are um
we end of august here and everywhere on
the planet
uh end of august so it is of course
chilly here in the pacific northwest it
is not chilly here because it is the end
of august august being the most perfect
month of the pacific northwest
it is in the high 70s low 80s it is
perfect here i haven't checked in in the
last hour but it was chilly earlier it's
gorgeous out
um
we're going to talk to you a little bit
about reality and whether or not we
shall be allowed to uh to abide by it uh
in in modern times we've got a number of
other things to talk uh to you about
today but all of them have to do a
little bit with whether or not what we
are
seeing uh with our own eyes matches what
we are being told we're seeing or told
we have to do and uh as usual we come to
you from an evolutionary perspective a
scientific perspective and and from
portland and and from a portland
perspective that's not
a heterodox portland perspective indeed
but you know we will say as we said
before uh that here in portland uh a
city that we we do in fact love
uh we are stopped on the street often
when we're out
by other portlanders who say thank you
and so you know we thank you and for
those of you that you know the vast
majority of our audience who's not in
portland and the some of our audience
who imagines that everything that
happens in portland is insane
no you're wrong there are a whole lot of
people here who are awesome
awake
amazing and cannot believe what is
happening to this this beautiful city
yep yeah i get stopped on the the street
and i hear that message and then i get
stopped in the street if i
choose to drive at the wrong hour
because of the traffic
it's it you know just stopped in and on
the street it's just
the nature of portland for us we can
move right off i don't understand what's
happening
um
so we have a q a after this as we always
do you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
i'm not sure if odyssey is working
zachary
okay so we have chat live on odyssey you
can go to uh the same channel brett
weinstein on odyssey that's odysse
if you're watching live or if you're not
but if you're watching live you can join
the chat there
uh we have i i am not going to talk a
lot about it today but uh my my
substance natural selections i i wrote a
piece this week on fraud it's called on
fraud and being science-ish
and it is
very much apropos of this moment
unfortunately in time how how is it that
science has become so prone
to having people who are willing to
engage in fraud
at
basically being the voice of science
it's it's really quite uh it's beyond
unfortunate and is potentially going to
take us all down
so i encourage you to look at that if
you have not seen it
we are supported by our audience and we
thank you for that we appreciate you
subscribing to the channels liking
sharing both the full episodes and the
clips which you can find at
darkhorsepodcastclips on youtube on
odyssey
and of course we're
findable on all the podcast places and
spotify and everything um just a
reminder that last summer over a year
ago at this point youtube demonetized us
even though they demonetized us for um
things about which now it is understood
that we were right
and we're all along and just you know
ahead of the mainstream curve but it's
funny they haven't revisited their uh
their claims about us yeah right because
if the two things were really unrelated
whether we were right and uh whether we
were
uh somehow unacceptable in their eyes
for reasons that had nothing to do with
us uh right being correct here's the
thing we were right and we were careful
and uh
we didn't have to have been right
to have not deserved uh to have been
thrown off because such is the nature of
good faith scientific inquiry that you
will sometimes be wrong when you are
investigating
ideas and that is not a crime as it
turns out we were not wrong
but we are still demonetized so
this is just a reminder that that
happened and we appreciate
you sharing the good word about you know
what we are doing and of course
appreciate uh any other kinds of support
that you can give if you can afford it
on both of our patreons we have uh
conversations monthly tomorrow sunday
august 28th it's going to be
we have our monthly private q a
the questions are already asked but it's
a small enough group that we actually
engage the chat and uh and they're able
to
answer questions that come up uh in real
time that's starting at a.m pacific on
sunday august 28th 28th
uh which you can find at my patreon and
brett has
come
smaller yet conversations on the first
saturdays and sundays of every month so
those will be happening next week
we encourage you to join us there
you can also at either of our patreons
get access to our amazing discord
community where
there are conversations about difficult
topics you can join a book club karaoke
virtual
happy hour and you're never at risk of
cancelled for having an
uh
an opinion that isn't shared widely by
others uh you may get pushback you may
get disagreed with you could be lightly
ridiculed but yes and and you may be
wrong and you may be told so and that is
as it should be i'm not saying that um
yeah i don't actually know to what
degree any of that happens especially
the ridicule but it's possible right
it's possible
and uh it's everyone
there whom we have talked to in the
discord community that you can access
through either of our patreons uh
reports it being just a really warm and
welcoming community and in fact they've
got a um a camping trip planned around
the sales
equinox
um no solstice no equinox sorry yup um i
think i think the email i got maybe said
solstice since the it's gonna be the
equinox maybe i'm just making stuff up
here but there's a camping trip planned
um with people who who met there on the
discord you would want to pack
differently for for the solstice you
would but you'd have longer to do so yes
true you'd definitely be able to get
your ducks in a row
unless they've migrated out probably
will have migrated by that in which case
but they migrated in a row or a v yeah
get your ducks in a v
that's actually
a way better sentiment it is yeah yeah
um and of course we have sponsors and as
as always i will i will remind all of
our regular listeners and tell any new
listeners or viewers that
we pick we choose from among the
sponsors who approach us very carefully
and we only we only have sponsors whose
products and services we actually vouch
for so without further ado here we go
three ads this week as usual
our first sponsor this week is new to us
and we are as always thrilled to be
working with them wisdom health is a
healthcare service that matches people
with functional medicine doctors to
streamline the process of returning you
to health or helping you maintain your
health so that you can do everything you
want to do in the world
many weird that is western educated
industrialized rich democratic
people
suffer from nagging health issues like
persistent digestive problems or skin
breakouts or chronic pain
others may feel low energy or sluggish
or burnt out and not know what to do
about it as we discussed here on dark
horse a lot and in a hunter-gatherer's
guide to the 21st century our book that
came out
almost a year ago
hyper novelty is at the root of many of
those problems the rate of change that
we are inflicting on ourselves outpaces
even humanity's considerable ability to
respond to it
conventional doctors employing
allopathic medicine are increasingly not
up to the challenge
diagnosis takes a back seat to
alleviating symptoms you barely know
your doctor appointments are rushed and
the upshot is often meds rather than
true solutions
even many supposedly chronic conditions
are reversible it turns out if you
address the root cause
wisdom health is a revolutionary service
that matches you with a leading
functional medicine doctor to help you
address your health issues your doctor
will spend 60 minutes with you a full
hour and go deep into all your health
issues to find solutions that truly work
wisdom health doctors help you dive deep
into your health and create a
personalized plan just for you
unlike conventional doctors they use
diet and targeted lifestyle changes to
help you address your real underlying
health issues
functional medicine can be extremely
expensive but wisdom health
pre-negotiates industry leading rights
for you
appointments with a functional medicine
doctor are just 189
and functional nutritionists are just
115
join wisdom health today book with your
choice of amazing practitioners and
start your journey back to full vibrant
well-being wisdom health is truly a new
kind of health care join today and get
100 off your first appointment at
wisdomhealth.com
darkhorse
our second sponsor this week is mudwater
that's mud
slash
backslash i never know which wtr which
one is that is that a slash or a
backslash uh that's a backslash that's a
backslash okay mud backslash wtr mud
water mud water is a coffee alternative
made with mushrooms herbs and spices
it's got a seventh the caffeine is a cup
of coffee so you get energy without the
anxiety jitters or crash of coffee if
that happens to you more to the point i
think it's really quite delicious
each ingredient was added with intention
mud water has cacao and chai lines main
mushrooms cordyceps chaga and reishi
turmeric and cinnamon
this is a terrific product either on its
own or as a warm drink in the morning
you can drink it black or with cream or
honey or both mud water also makes a
non-dairy creamer out of coconut milk
and mct and a sweetener out of coconut
palm sugar and lucuma which is the fruit
of an andean tree which is used by the
inca you can add those if you prefer
those options if you want to sweeten it
or
or cream it up a little bit without
actually using dairy
there's definitely a hint of chocolate
in the flavor and from the cacao and the
masala chai blend including ginger and
cardamom nutmeg and cloves brings a
delicious spiciness to it
i've been adding it into a smoothie with
a banana and ice some delicious locally
made entirely nut milk mint and cacao
nibs it's totally delicious and they've
got a wonderful new caffeine-free
product designed to be a drink for
before bed which i also love mud water
is 100 usda organic non-gmo gluten free
vegan and kosher certified mud water
allows you to build a morning ritual
that promotes sustained energy without
the crash visit mudwater.com darkhorse
to support the show and use darkhorse at
checkout for fifteen percent off that's
m u d w t r dot com slash dark horse use
darkhorse at checkout for 15 off
and our final sponsor today we not only
love their product but we also at least
i also love their spelling
um our final product our final uh
sponsor is element that is lmnt
element getting rid of all those
extraneous vowels right
you don't need them you can just read it
right off the page element is an
electrolyte drink mix that has
everything you need and nothing you
don't it's got a lot of salts at 1 000
milligrams of sodium 200 milligrams of
potassium 60 milligrams of magnesium but
has no sugar no coloring no artificial
ingredients no gluten yay and no fillers
electrolytes facilitate hundreds of
functions in the body including the
conduction of nerve impulses hormonal
regulation and nutrient absorption
element can help prevent and eliminate
headaches muscle cramps and
sleeplessness
we have heard from several friends
independently uh
how much they like element they drink it
every day and feel better doing so when
you sweat the primary electrolyte lost
is sodium athletes can lose up to seven
grams per day element is formulated to
help anyone with their electrolyte needs
and is perfectly suited to folks
following keto low carb or paleo diets
element is not just for athletes though
anyone being active may find a benefit
from element even drinking a few glasses
of wine can leave you depleted an
element can help if you're feeling
depleted or dehydrated drink water and
consider element as well
right now element is offering our
listeners a free sample pack with any
purchase that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order this
is a great way to try all eight flavors
or share element with a salty friend
get yours at
drinkelement.com
horse this deal is only available
through our link you must go to
d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t
dot com slash darkhorse element offers a
no questions asked refund
try it totally risk-free if you don't
like it share it with a salty friend and
they will give you your money back no
questions asked um you have nothing to
lose
it seems to me that you would share it
with a less salty friend to make them
get make them become more salty right a
salt deficient friend yes right exactly
um
no i i agree you'll have to amend the
text the script yes yes
all right
uh here we are here we are uh shall we
start can we start by talking about
whether or not reality shall be
tolerated
yes i mean as you point out particularly
the overarching question
from here on until we either uh
surrender and give in to the postmodern
apocalypse or resurrect the concept that
reality both exists and uh shall be
something upon which we reach agreement
through you know like a process of
rationality
you use it as the basis for decisions
for instance wow wouldn't that be
something can you imagine government
governance based on on reality ah now
you're dreaming inferred through you
know like science and things
yeah i can i can actually
and i would like to insist on it
although i'm not your mind in that
position yeah but we can recommend it
they can't stop well they can't stop us
from doing that yeah so far they've
incompletely stopped us from
recommending reality
to uh your
patients who chew them here we go i'm
sure we're over in misdis and mal
information territory once again
recommending reality to help you with
your everyday needs once you see that
solution set it's kind of a big
territory
it is it is so i just i have three
um
three examples of reality not being
tolerated here that we're going to talk
about uh before we move on to the other
things in the podcast today one from
just some you know random anonymous
account on the internet on twitter
one from rando oh a rando if you will
which you will and perhaps they will
already did
we
we have
reality being denied by
arando
reality being denied by
a magazine that purports to be spreading
these scientific discoveries to the lay
people and reality being denied by the
actual scientific journals that are
supposed to be the place where new
scientific discoveries are first
revealed to
scientific colleagues scientific
colleagues
and um
the tone
changes between these three
domains as you might expect the rando
and the scientific journal don't sound
exactly the same they don't use exactly
the same language but it is remarkable
that all three of them are consistent in
just denying
what is true so here we go
uh the rando as
as you if you insist
uh here we go zach this is from twitter
this is from august 18th from a
anonymous account
at queersing
if bioconservatives managed to stop
doctors from formally providing gender
affirming body modification to minors
underground alternatives will
proliferate younger folks yearn for
morphological freedom too and will do
what they can to live as they wish
hashtag diy
transliberation
now morphological freedom
is a new one on me
and uh you know don't show my screen
again here zack but if you look at the
bio for this account you will perhaps
not be surprised to learn that the first
phrase in it is queer transhumanist
anarchist
so this is a very transhumanist approach
that uh we are we we are somehow
separate from our bodies we can be more
fully separated from our bodies our true
being exists outside of the somatic
existence of us
and uh all we need is more and better
tech in order to realize this amazing
dream
it is uh
you know for some it sounds utopian for
others of us it sounds dystopian but
regardless of what you think about it
it's just wrong right you know we we are
our embodied experience we experience
things through our bodies and from that
develop the senses of what it is to
think of the world and how to engage in
it there is no separating us so this
morphological freedom idea which is very
much downstream of transhumanism
is out of alignment with what is true
with with the fact of you know some
small number of
billions of years of evolution in which
we have been embodied yeah and you know
of course this
drives you into
should a person be free to
morphologically alter their body well
certainly an adult person has some
right to do this within reason but it is
also the case
that we recognize
that this
desire may indeed be pathological and
that it is not in our interest to
facilitate it right whether that
technical right still exists
for an adult
it is certainly our obligation to
protect children from that impulse you
know to take cutting for example
right to the extent that people injure
themselves they have psychological
reasons to do it clearly but the point
is this is they may be doing something
to control a different harm but
nonetheless the point is this is a harm
landscape and the idea that just because
we phrase it you know
uh as if it is just a simple extension
of some principle you know do we believe
in you know individual autonomy well
certainly well how about morphological
autonomy right how about you know why
would you deny it to children and it's
like you're just being marched in the
direction of you know actually endorsing
uh harm and and there's more too you
know something we've talked about here
before
which is that uh trans being real but
rare and um and i actually actually know
someone who did
do a diy
surgery on themselves because they were
they had such extreme gender dysphoria
and it is excruciating and tragic and
uh and you know that that does happen
however
the idea that
modern weird people have come up with an
ability with high technology
to
to
modify bodies
does not mean that you have a basic
human right to the very novel very
technological discoveries of the last
some years
every moment every discovery that
moderns make does not immediately become
a right right and and you know the idea
of you know the fundamental human right
to bodily autonomy is quite different
from there being any fundamental human
right to
taking advantage of every newest
possible technological or medical
uh
not not innovation like just treatment
or surgery or procedure
especially especially given how off the
rails it is given how reductionist and
and
uninterested in diagnosis and hyper
focused on dealing with symptoms it is
there's going to be a lot of disaster
downstream
now i agree with your point of course
and we've we've talked about this before
that there is a
a large body of evidence that across
many cultures there is a trans
phenomenon of one type or another i'm
not aware of any in which this involves
surgical modification but
the point is we are in a radical new
territory when the point is uh you know
i am trans and therefore i need to be
physically modified or need to be
physiologically modified
with hormone treatments or blockers or
whatever and so the point is that's
where this becomes
a remarkable new
argument
this strikes me as the next phase of an
arms race right because
the basic point is well if you're going
to say well trans is real but it has
never included the right to surgical
modification nor the necessity of it
right so if we want those modifications
and the medical establishment decides
that it cannot in good conscience
deliver them at least to people below a
certain age then
we will avail ourselves of the right to
modify our own bodies which is of course
as you point out a threat it can't
possibly be safe to do it right somebody
who does not have the training to do
this in a way that is uh
biotically safe that doesn't risk the
possibility of uh damaging a blood
vessel and bleeding out i mean it's
obviously extremely dangerous well i
mean self surgery
yes insane
yes even surgeons don't do it yes
it's even it's even more dangerous than
cutting your own hair
really yes wow substantially more so i
know i i
i will uh i will i will dredge up the
research literature that explains why
that is i look forward to seeing that
yeah
the side-by-side comparison
right they weren't physically side by
side but in the paper it's two charts
all right i have now diverted this
conversation indeed madness um but yeah
it's a threat and the point is
of course civilization has the right to
say um
your your right to live as you wish to
live is not tantamount to a right to
surgical modification certainly before
you have attained uh adulthood and this
is this is next phase which is then
we'll do it ourselves yep
and i mean i guess before we move on to
the
to the next example
some things are just not available to
you
they're just they're just not and
um just because you can imagine
something or fantasize about it doesn't
mean it
can be or should be real or possible to
you i'm reminded i'm reminded of the
rolling stones
yes right um
uh
you can't always have what you want
but it's get what you want you can't
always get what you want right but if
you try sometimes you might find you
might find you can get what you need yep
get in both cases yeah it's good it's
good it's good um
i feel like you know they they're before
our time a bit but
was it that song that played in our high
school graduation richards is timeless
maybe even physiologically but
the band yes
before so they were classic they were
classic rock at the point that we were
in high school but i believe it was that
song that actually
was that song that we that was played at
our high school graduation or is it a
different rolling stone song oh it may
well have been that one i've completely
forgotten this but you've blocked that
was so it was so traumatic for you
well i was uh you were the speaker at
our graduation
keeping an eye on o.j
it was also at our graduation yes he was
okay um he had already long since
graduated but um
but his daughter anyway
in any case i've done it again yes
yes you have yes you have um
really
it wasn't so long ago
that it felt like
the advances
from civil rights and women's rights and
gay rights were
were happening we weren't there but we
were clearly moving in the right
direction and we understood that there
were trade-offs
and that
frankly you can't always get what you
want
but
but if you try sometimes you might find
you can get what you need
i think it's you get what you know you
can get with you you're right um
i stepped all over your line sorry about
that but uh i you're much better with
lyrics than i am um well i i can't
forget them yeah they plagued me but uh
yeah because some of them aren't great
but anyway i digress
yet again
um
i have now lost what i wanted to add to
that discussion i have no sympathy for
you i hoisted on my own petard in this
case in this case i have no sympathy for
you in this case yeah
um
yeah i really don't have it
okay oh hello
um
so next example we have
cats are all over the place it's chaos
here today yeah here we go um
sorry for those of you listening you
must be wondering what the hell is going
on
uh
magazines that exist to disseminate
scientific findings to the public uh
such as is natural history still in
existence or to disappear it used to be
a great magazine and then it went nuts
even before everyone else went nuts or
it went uninteresting as far as i know
it's still okay well natural history
discover scientific american these are
um omni is that a magazine i make that
mm-hmm yeah that was
never as much in my
in my world but those those first three
like we got those in my house when i was
growing up
uh and they were you know they were
understood to be the ways that
scientifically interested people
uh can keep up on scientific findings
either outside of their own fields if
they're scientists or outside of you
know or they're not scientists but
they're scientifically capable and
interested and literate and want to want
to know what's what's what yeah it was
the popular presentation of
actual
scientific discovery exactly and there
you know there was there was some
controversial stuff and there are things
that you know you might disagree with
because that's the way science works uh
and
um and there are also interpretations of
things you know whether or not the
finding
turns out to be true or not the
interpretation of it
may separately uh not not be the right
interpretation
um
but scientific american
has i mean long since jumped all the
sharks
it feels like not that that's a thing
uh but
here here we have
uh here i'll put up their tweet before
actually yeah you can you can just put
this this is again i picked this up from
twitter
where i quote tweet scientific american
and what scientific american has said is
this
before the late 18th century hopefully
that's not playing
okay before the late 18th century
western science recognized only one sex
the male and considered the female body
an inferior version of it the shift
historians called the two sex models
serve mainly to reinforce gender and
racial divisions by tying social status
to the body
true facts about the male
so what what i said in response which is
you know it's an understatement where
any scientific publication forgets that
reality exists whether or not humans
perceive it accurately
the idea that because
that because science didn't understand
everything about the universe at some
point
there must not have been a reality then
and
our confusion now can take precedence
and we can use confusion from earlier to
cement confusions now is
truly backwards and like i just i keep
on coming back to the fermi paradox and
thinking like this is it this is this is
the kind of society ending confusion
that keeps us from ending up making
contact with other conscious beings in
the universe because if this
then there's there's no amazing space
exploration for us like we can't do it
we can't do it if we think these things
right um yes the colonizing of other
planets will be much more difficult if
we have not at least ensured that people
from
the two actual genuine sexes who are
still of reproductive age have arrived
in these places capable of producing
offspring um but i would just point out
that even you know
who
amongst us does not in their own mind
have
rock-solid evidence that people
have been aware of the sexual binary
for
two plus thousand years right two plus
thousand wow okay well i'm just saying
if the idea that it is this was
discovered in the 1880s
18 somethings i don't know
let's make it the 1880s something okay
like the 1880s right
the average person
knows
that
the old testament for example contains a
certain number of references to the two
sexes suggesting that people
that far back already had become aware
of this this binary yeah right so
how is it that scientific america and
really i think we need a new category
because the purpose there is not to
convince anybody of this nor is this the
product of anything that even rises to
the level of a confusion right the
purpose of this is if you wish
to deny
the absolutely obvious and
incontrovertible fact of two human sexes
then you're going to need something to
work with in other words there comes the
point in the conversation where you wish
to assert that there are not two sexes
and the person on the other side of the
argument says hopefully in a respectful
way you're completely full of [ __ ] and
then you need to say the next thing
right about why you're not full of [ __ ]
and so
the purpose of this is to have that next
thing in hand and to have it come from a
respectable place like scientific
american because then the person who has
called you out for your garbage thinking
is then back on their heels they may not
have a next thing in which case you win
and there are no longer two sexes that's
right that's right because that's how
reality works guys that is how reality
is how reality works and that's why
we'll never meet aliens wait wait wait
that is how reality has always worked
now i need scientific american to give
me the peace that i say when you call me
out for being full of [ __ ] i'm sure
they're coming with it well no doubt i'm
sure they will so actually this strikes
me it hadn't occurred to me before um
but during your your brief tirade there
i thought about quantities
and so cuatis c-o-a-t-i um also known as
quatermundis
are a neo-tropical that is to say uh
the tropics in the new world in the
americas
procyonid which is uh relative of the
raccoon they are they're gorgeous
they're snouty and they're brown and
they've got some stripes further back
not as stripy as the raccoon no um more
brown they're um they're forest dwellers
um they climb okay like raccoons climb
okay and they just they're they're quite
lovely that i think the first time we
ran into them and you've actually got a
picture of me sitting next to one and
was in monteverde in uh in costa rica in
the cloud forest on the first summer
that we spent backpacking through
central america it was near the end of
our trip
um but what we heard i believe on that
trip for the first time and we've heard
it since although because i had hadn't
occurred to me i have not gone back and
looked into the research here what we
heard then was that when researchers
first when western researchers were
first under discovering the quantum
money the quota monday presumably having
long since discovered itself as the
original human inhabitants of these
forests having nonsense discovered them
but when western science came in it was
like aha
i have found it eureka the quantum mundi
don't exist until it has a latin name it
won't exist until it has a latin name
such as the nature of science and
reality apparently um but now when when
the quantum mundi was discovered i don't
know this is maybe in the 1880s um you
know early 20th century mid 20th century
something
uh it was thought that there were two
species
because one of them uh which was i don't
remember but i'm gonna guess maybe a
little bit larger body was always seen
um singly and it was like oh wait did
you see it that was a i think that was
maybe called the quadi that was the
quality and then there were these like
aggregates there were these ones they
always had little ones with them and
they had a lot of bigger ones and they
were called the mundis i guess
and as it turns out the mundis were the
females with their babies and they were
social because often females with babies
are and the quatties uh were the males
that were solitary it's a palligenous
mating system and it all fits together
now that we have a better understanding
of mating systems and biology and no
that doesn't change the underlying
reality about what quaties or quantum
undies are
but it does mean that science got it
wrong science got it wrong and then
through a an experiment in which they
checked the junk of the
pilates and quantum monies they
discovered being procyonids being
raccoon relatives was not too easy it
was a task yeah it was a it was a they
got scratched up no doubt but um yeah
and boy the nsf grant for that junk
checking in quantities i think it had a
different title but anyway
it's not the only story of this kind in
fact the elephant seal went through the
same thing um so there are two species
of elephant seal and i forget which one
it was but the the thing is that
morphologically elephant seals are so
different males and females are so
different in size and also facial
structure the males
even uglier than the females which if
you've ever seen a female elephant seal
you might find difficult to believe but
now take a look at a male even uglier
yeah a lot of a lot of uh resonance all
the same snazzle stuff going on but
anyway they were understood to be
different species until again a junk
checking experiment uh revealed the
truth i want to know what division of
nsf that is like where you apply for the
nsf grant for children right next door
to naval gazing oh yeah yeah um okay
yeah and it's these departments are
expanding they're taking over
yeah apparently
taking over the whole nsf oh man okay so
um saturday of american has lost the
plot
the internet randos
obviously some of them started off
without having the plot so okay
scientific american has lost the plot
they've not lost the plot they have
plotted against the plot oh they're
actively plotting against the plot yes
okay
but then also the scientific journals
and you know we've we've talked about
this uh a lot in other domains with
regard to you know covety stuff
but here we go this is um a slightly
different topic well it's a it's it
includes the topic we're just on but
uh and it's an op-ed in the journal
nature human behavior so nature being
one of the two most prestigious
scientific journals in the world the
scientific journals being the places
that you uh you having done
your own research
submit for publication so that's where
you're that's where the record of the
research lives forever and ever and ever
and nature and science are the two
biggest ones considered the most
prestigious and nature unlikes i don't
think science has this but nature has a
bunch of like sub journals and so you've
got like nature genetics nature
biotechnology i think nature human
behavior is one of them it wasn't one of
the ones i happened to have heard of
even though it's exactly in our
wheelhouse but nature human behavior is
is wonderful so they
that fissioning began
when we were in grad school yeah in the
90s it must have continued yes exactly
because i think nature genetics may have
been one of the first
there were a few very prestigious ones
and apparently it worked and so they
yeah so spun off a few more exactly
and so you know it's it's a scientific
journal um under the umbrella of one of
the two most prestigious scientific
journals but it also has there's also
always news stories as opposed to
primary uh
primary scientific findings being
recorded and reported there and also
some op-eds so this is an op-ed
from the editors of nature human
behavior who remember are effectively
the gatekeepers of what shall get
published in what amounts to
one of the most prestigious places that
you can get your
uh research published um so i will link
to this actual link on uh in the show
notes but if you could take my screen
off for a moment sac so that i can just
go to my pdf where i have some things
highlighted oh where did it go
okay so here we go
uh
this let me make it a little bit bigger
so people can see it this is the same
nature human behavior op-ed published i
can't remember just a few days ago i
think
in which science must respect the
dignity and rights of all humans is the
title subtitle new ethics guidance
addresses potential harms for human
population groups who do not participate
in research but may be harmed by its
publication
first very first sentence is although
academic freedom is fundamental it is
not unbounded
just a few
i recommend that you read this whole
thing um but let's
let me just read the things i've
highlighted and let's talk about them
there is a fine balance between academic
freedom and the protection of the
dignity and rights of individuals and
human groups
they attest
probably true
but so you don't have to write anything
down you can respond to that well i just
wanted to point out that that initial
assertion
um not the academic freedom is
fundamental it's fundamental
but it's not unbounded freedom is not
unbounded right
that sounds
so reasonable
and yet
it ought to immediately set off alarm
bells about what exactly they are about
to steal from you in terms of rights
that you had before that you don't have
now and really at least they don't bury
the lead right it's a little cryptic but
they don't bury it it's right there well
they don't bury it but they yeah cryptic
is the point because
really i don't know at the point i read
a sentence like that i don't know if i
need to immediately stand up and object
and say that's where the bodies are
going to be buried or if they're going
to say something mundane like you know
you're not allowed to murder people in
your laboratory you know academic
freedom is fundamental but it's not
unbounded you can't murder people in
your laboratory well i agree you know
but does that mean there are things i
can't
say
does it mean that there it turns out yes
true things i can't say in which case
that's where the goddamn
bodies are buried yes
yes that's exactly right
okay so again
i agree okay this is where the fact of
adobe being a little obnoxious there we
go okay
[Music]
harm's going to rise as a direct result
of the conduct of research sure of
course harms can also arise indirectly
you can show my screen if you like zack
harms can also arise indirectly as a
result of the publication of a research
project or a piece of scholarly
communication for instance
stigmatization of a vulnerable human
group or potential use of the results of
research for unintended purposes eg
public policies that undermine human
rights or misuse of information to
threaten public health
that's an extraordinary
half a paragraph as well they're now
claiming
that
if someone abuses the research that you
have done
you are in some ways accountable for
their abuse of your findings therefore
that is going to be their justification
implicitly mostly here but partially
explicitly that is going to be their
justification for therefore
we're going to save you from yourself
here we're going to save you from doing
any research which could possibly be
misunderstood in any way by any
nefarious actors which of course means
that's the end of research
that's it we're done
it's over imagine the following right
imagine
a periodic table
in which nitrogen has to be removed
because knowledge about nitrogen is
indeed prone to misuse it is right that
stuff is explosive and you see what i'm
saying sodium also get rid of that one
you know yeah so i mean
what are they even i see a very rapid
shrinking of the periodic table given
this yeah there's not going to be much
left
yeah it's hard to find an element that
you couldn't abuse an innocent element
there are none
yeah no i mean if if innocence means
not only are you not guilty of harm but
you are not you are not guilty of having
been misunderstood to be guilty of harm
yes i guess some of the transuranics
are so vanishingly rare and last for
such a tiny fraction of a second that
maybe they are beyond what they're
called transuranics yeah
wow well there it is i didn't know that
learned something it's just like just
right right above right just slightly
larger than uranium yeah yeah yeah
um
but anyway yeah the periodic table is
pretty much a goner there's some there
are maybe a few elements that we can
keep but most of them have to be gone
but imagine whoever used it anyway
i'm not going to start naming names
i'm certainly not going to try to spell
them but
in any case the the the
i'm sure mendeleev was a racist or
something well a lot of people had a lot
of defects and a lot of other people
have used their work and
the problem is the two universes
a universe downstream of that paragraph
yeah
that is
i mean um
let's put it this way this term will
become important again on dark horse
soon but that is the fast track to a
dark age
if you are not allowed to study things
that could be abused by
others
right i mean
that is a completely unscientific
universe there is no science in that
universe right because who even knows
are you allowed to study things that you
don't know if they could be abused until
your work is done well you probably
can't do that work either for the same
reason but i mean it also completely
puts it puts all the power in the hands
of anyone who wants to abuse anything i
mean this like you know darwinism has
been suffering this fate basically since
darwin where the so-called social
darwinists who you know stole the word
and now forever after us evolutionary
biologists who are actually trying to do
good work are accused of being
eugenicists and racists and nazis and
all this is like you know that was an
abuse of darwinism and i write about
this actually in my fraud piece and
natural selections this week like
the fact that someone used the word
darwinism and fundamentally
misunderstood what the guy was on about
isn't on us isn't on the evolutionary
biologists just as the fact that some
research could be abused by some you
know idiot or
[ __ ]
actually is not the responsibility of
the person doing the research it's not
not it's not the responsibility of the
person doing the research and here you
have the
a journal in the family of journals that
is one of the premier outlets for
science in the world that has declared
if that's if that paragraph stands they
have declared war on the idea of science
and you're right the extrapolation
the paragraph if it was applied fairly
ends science completely what it will do
instead is exactly what you point to
which is it will give the power to
define what science has tolerated yes it
will leave that completely arbitrary
power in the hands of those uh awful
enough to
wish to utilize that weapon so only the
stuff you know the abuses they want will
proceed and the abuses they or the
legitimate uses will not that's right
that's right
okay another another choice another
paragraph another two paragraphs in this
case it's not a long op-ed uh i could
have just highlighted the whole thing
but here we go you may show my screen if
you like zack regardless of content type
research review or opinion and for
research regardless of whether a
research project was reviewed and
approved by an appropriate institutional
ethics committee editors reserve the
right to request modifications to
or correct or otherwise amend
post-publication and in severe cases
refuse publication of or retract
post-publication colon i'm going to keep
reading here but
i don't care what is about to happen
as it turns out it's bad but i don't
care what's about to happen
editors reserve the right to amend
post-publication
they're there what like you you you
submit
your precious research to a journal and
it goes through peer review and it goes
through edits and edits and edits and
edits and it's published
and the editors of this journal are
saying actually we might change what it
says that you said after it's published
that's insane let me just get let me
read the next paragraph here what you
know and there's four points that they
make i'm just going to read the first
one
so the the reasons by which they may for
instance just change afterwards what uh
what
what they already published of yours
includes
content that is premised upon the
assumption of inherent biological
social or cultural superiority or
inferiority of one human group over
another based on race ethnicity national
or social origin sex gender identity
sexual orientation religion political or
other beliefs age disease disability or
other socially constructed or socially
relevant oops
groupings hereafter referred to as
socially constructed or socially
relevant human
groupings
now there's a lot there
obviously
uh let's just pick the low-hanging fruit
the low-hanging fruit there's a lot of
low-hanging fruit here but one of them
is
content that is prime i'm just going to
skip to content that is premised upon
the assumption of
social or cultural superiority or
inferiority
based on
sex
okay
women are better than men
at seeing the details of situations
and men are better than women at seeing
the gist i have talked about this before
i have the paper uh on which that
conclusion is based
and it's a sort of a forest for the
trees and trees for the forest question
this holds across a number of domains
and
it is also true for instance
that on average women are better than
men in linguistic tasks and on average
men are better than women in strictly
mathematical tasks that's not to say
that the best living mathematician might
not be a man or the best living author
might not be
uh rather that the best living
mathematician might not be a woman or
the best living author might not be a
man
i am talking about average
differences between groups this is what
we do
okay and some of some of what they're
trying to do here is say your categories
are wrong your categories are lies and
some of the categories that that science
has used and that people have used in
the past have been lies have been wrong
are based on stereotypes that do not
hold water
but just to just to go up to the
low-hanging fruit here sex
again
is real
is not a creation of the victorian era
scientists it is in fact real and on
average there are differences between us
that are actually
biological social and cultural all of
those things and the cultural and social
differences will vary somewhat across
guess what culture
and the idea that we cannot talk about
that and cannot do research into that
well once again
end of science and furthermore and then
the way you talk like
what's this journal called nature human
behavior like that's the journal in
which they say you cannot talk about
biological social or cultural
differences
or you're allowed to talk about
differences as long as you claim
but it's all equally good no matter what
we're all equally awesome we all get
cold stars on our foreheads and we can
all go over there and sit in the corner
and freaking cry because we no longer
have any reason to aspire to anything
because we all think we're equally good
as everyone else and therefore what's
the point anyway i mean it also takes
away the desire to actually aspire to
things to imagine that you're equally
good as everyone else already is and
that's it you're done
so you have the editors
at a premier outlet reserving the right
to alter your work after it comes in or
prevent the work from being published
right yes
but
the point is
people who are not in academia will not
understand the power of a top journal
basically saying what conclusions it's
willing to publish not on the basis that
other conclusions may not be right but
on the basis that other conclusions
could be abused right
what they're doing is they're saying
here are the conclusions that are
acceptable here now a
imagine what does that mean over at you
know whatever the proper
sub-journal of nature is where climate
science happens
do they also have a policy that only
science that pushes in the direction of
policy modifications in which we address
climate change will be published and in
which case on what basis do we say
things like
x percent of scientists in climate
science agree if the point is well
there's this force that says basically
you're not going to get very far in
climate science if you don't agree right
it becomes circular and so in a circular
world
where you cannot talk about the
superiority of men or women at different
tasks where men and women are
differently capable um what happens is
you will then over time produce
the phony scientific impression of
similarity
which will then be used to counter the
argument so basically this is a positive
feedback anybody who wishes to say no
actually men and women are different
they have different capabilities and we
know that the evidence is clear
well the evidence actually yes the
science used the evidence used to be
clear but it has become increasingly
clear that men and women are not
different
why because of editorial uh
overreach at the journals actually and i
had something else to say here but that
reminds me
of the next two little things that i
wanted to read from this where they have
working definitions adopted and or
adapted from the sager guidelines and
other sources i don't remember what oh
sega is sex and gender equity in
research
i didn't go down that rabbit hole i'm
sure it's ugly
um sex
refers to currently understood
biological differences
gender refers to socially constructed
and enacted roles and behaviors which
occur in historical and cultural
contexts and vary across societies over
time
sex
well we currently understand this but we
all know that things change gender
though is this thing so they've got that
reversed again
sex has been around for you know not
very many billion of years
oh and gender
is the downstream effects of sex on your
behavior and lots of organisms have
gender and this gender identity crap
that is now taking over is a totally
made up 21st century thing that has no
bearing on anyone outside of well the
entire planet in its how we're going to
dissolve because we've all
oh i'm done i'm trying like oh my god so
you started with the low hanging fruit
which i think is wise yeah right
the sexes are different for a reason
right selection made them different for
reason it's a division of labor issue
right
that's and that doesn't mean it's good
right that doesn't mean it's great or
fantastic or fun or wonderful it's just
true it's just true and it means that it
is squarely within the uh subject matter
for legitimate science right right yes
we can talk about whether it's good or
bad or whether there's something to be
done to
change things that are unfair about it
because there are certainly some things
that are unfair right but yeah there's a
reason for instance that we're not sorry
but like in academia
there is an active discussion about how
to deal with the fact that in general
the years during which you are most
likely to be hardest at work doing
research and building your lab are also
the most likely to be your childbearing
years if you are a woman and tenure is
on a clock and how do you stop the
tenure clock or pause it or adjust it so
as to both allow for the fact that women
also have children when they choose to
but women also may want to be
high-powered academics and it's you you
cannot disappear the fact that there is
a trade-off there and there's going to
be a cost but there's an active often
good faith discussion about how to do
this how to make it fair both to male
academics
who
even if they are active active daddies
don't have to go through gestation and
lactation
sorry no male does
but uh
so that that's the kind of conversation
that we can have and that we should be
having and hey we were having
in the 80s and 90s and aughts about what
the differences between the sexes
and moving beyond regressive old
expectations of gender roles means as we
move forward into a world in which
everyone has the ability to choose
freely from among their options about
what it is that they want to do with
their lives right and i mean in fact
we've
this is a demonstration that our ability
to talk openly about this issue actually
leads to solutions right because the
fact is academia has been democratized
between the sexes it didn't start out
that way but if you look at the number
of uh female phds graduating it exceeds
males in the sciences at least
um
uh in biology i don't think in the
sciences across the board uh
certainly not in engineering and
engineering it's it's it's highly skewed
as we would expect it to remain we want
to see a
composite analysis mds are are biased uh
towards towards women at this point uh
and i think a bit you know again this
you know this this old saw which is
based on research and which is true is
that on average women are more
interested in people and also organisms
and on average men are more interested
in things means that men are more likely
given freedom of choice to go into
things like engineering and math and
physics and chemistry and women are more
likely to go into medicine and
biology of whole organisms yep
all right but suffice it to say we have
addressed this problem and we did so not
by pretending that sex differences
didn't exist but by recognizing that
they had implications for career tracks
and by making reasonable changes to the
way
power was distributed in these
departments right but um
in any case i want to go
slightly higher up the tree and pick
some more difficult fruit okay because
this is done in a diabolical way yes it
is right by taking
what is obviously meant to imply
race and population and cultural
differences they are smuggling in the
ability to neutralize sex differences
sex differences are the easy one here
right what they're doing is they're
saying if you
balk at what we are asserting here then
you're probably a racist right so the
point is even sex in which this is such
a slam dunk that these differences exist
and are not controversial
in any circle where people are free to
just simply see the obvious
and the question is well what is the
relationship and i want to point out and
i should tell you i don't i shouldn't
have to explain what my position as a
biologist is on genetic differences
between populations but i will
because it's important for you to
understand what i say next and what it
does and doesn't imply
i personally am not a big believer that
significant differences in capacity
between human groups are
in the present largely based in genes
i think the genetic contribution is
little to none
however
it is certain
that differences have to have existed
between groups in order for selection to
have favored an overall increase in
human capacity so to the extent that
human beings are an anomalously
intelligent and capable species that
happened because human groups differed
in capacity and selection favored the
elaboration of human intelligence so the
idea
that somewhere in the the bulwark of the
journal nature that they are going to
declare war on the concept of
differences between human groups means
that we can
no longer talk about how humans became
so capable right we cannot talk about
the historical fact of differences
between populations and the fact that we
have all every living human population
has benefited massively from the fact
that selection apparently favored
greater human intelligence over less
human intelligence or hominid
intelligence yep so and i mean
so the i mean and the
the the level of irony here of nature
human behavior if hume why you know how
many there are four thousand ish mammal
species why
well either it's going to correct me to
five splitters lumpers the whole bit
there are four to five thousand
mammal species
why does one of them get its own journal
under the umbrella of nature
because where's nature kawaii behavior
right where is nature
kawadi and nature muskrat and all of
that right it's human behavior that gets
its own journal why is that that's
because humans are really unusual
how did they get unusual if there was
not selection between human ancestral
populations in which selection favored
the unusual traits that justify a
special journal at nature how could that
be that's right
so i guess
i'm going to go back down the tree a
little bit too easy easy hanging fruit
but based based on what you just said
remember that it reads uh content that
is premised upon the assumption of
inherent biological social or cultural
superiority or inferiority of one group
over another
now again i wasn't prepared for this but
there are some
groups of humans some particular unique
populations of humans
which qualifies as a human group
who engage in cannibalism
and that is a cultural trait that they
engage in and i am here to tell you that
i believe that that is an inferior
practice
to that which the rest of us do which is
not engaging you are going to run the
you are going to risk our channel on the
claim that cannibals are
there's an inferior cultural trait to
not being a cannibal
right
and that that right there is something
that i guess if i claimed
in a publication that i get in a paper
that got accepted by nature human
behavior they have they would have the
right to go in afterwards and correct
correct my claim and say actually
cannibalism
it has its advantages all right it's
fine it's at the very least we can't say
that it's any worse than not being a
cannibal okay i think this is a lovely
challenge um
but what about the case what suppose i
wanted to publish a paper in nature
human behavior in which i discussed the
effect on the carrying capacity of a
given habitat under hunting and
gathering versus farming and i was to
point out that the farming population on
the same patch of territory was uh you
know 10 times the size of what was
sustained under it allows for a higher
population density am i allowed to argue
that that would be evolutionarily
superior am i allowed to notice if
uh farming populations have driven out
hunting uh populations or caused them to
embrace uh farming in history are we
allowed to have that conversation right
and and so
evolutionarily superior
made more of itself right and you know
superior for
the people who are the hunter-gatherers
no worse for them superior for the land
in which the farming took place not
necessarily and once we're talking about
monocropping and big egg definitely not
worse i mean definitely not better much
much worse
but produces more of the people that the
thing was created to produce
yeah so success
better at the thing
doesn't address the but was the thing
itself desirable no actually maybe we
don't want to be facilitating producing
more and more and more of ourselves
right so i mean that like just the idea
of like what is superior and what is
inferior like what is the goal
and is the goal itself honorable or
something that we want to be engaged in
we need to be able to have every single
level of this conversation you need to
be able to say actually
low-intensive
multi-crop
sweden agriculture
allows for more people to be maintained
on a piece of land than does hunter
gathering
and
mona big ag mono cropping agriculture in
the short term especially with the you
know
nitrogen fixing
chemicals that have been that were
created in the early 20th century and
are now being added a lot uh to the land
allows for even more people to persist
but at what cost all these downstream
effects all of which are externalities
none of which are being added into the
equation
the intermediate agricultural
and there are lots of lots of ranges of
approaches to to
to agriculturing the land that's not the
way you say it but um we'll will produce
more people than hunter-gathering but
how how honorable is it and how valuable
is it to humanity long-term
that we simply decide that more people
is
success and therefore better and we're
going to let the the hunter-gatherers
disappear
that's also not good that's it's it's
not an honorable decision to have made
but if we're if we are prevented from
talking about which you know which kind
of way of being
makes more makes less
does you know if we can't make any
judgments at all
we can't have the conversations like
we're done with the conversation
so
are we allowed
under this rubric to talk about the fact
that europeans who traveled to the new
world had superior immunity to smallpox
because the new world populations
because they came from the land of
smallpox because they came from a land
in which people had close association
with uh
they had animal husbandry because the
animals that were capable of being
domesticated are
highly concentrated in the old
if you want to be liberated from the
idea that the reason that the
populations that have power today uh are
in power is that they were genetically
superior the key to unhooking that idea
is jared diamond right understanding
that what was uneven was the
distribution of opportunities to do
things like domesticate and the accident
of the like the major geographic access
on which the continent that you were on
went absolutely which then shows you
exactly why europeans were so successful
at uh
driving out native populations in the
americas and so unsuccessful when they
tried to move north through africa the
orientation of the continents reversed
the tables on the germs so
the the
reverse the tables on the germs and the
domesticated crops that they brought
with them so the point is if you want
the antidote to the racist [ __ ] you
need the science to be done completely
and you need to you know biological
social and cultural
really none of that we're not allowed to
talk about any of that anymore what
you're left with
is exactly what you're talking about
you're opening the door wide to the
actual racists the you know the the
actual people who have no clue what is
going on and are looking for an excuse
to be terrible to one another
that's what we are doing here even worse
i mean that is exactly what we were
doing at a power level but even worse
right
human behavior there are two ways you
could study it right you could study it
in a darwinian framework which yes is
going to tell you some things you don't
want to know it's also going to give you
the keys to making history fair
right
or you can study it in an anti-darwinian
framework in which differences in
capacity are not allowed to be discussed
in which case you are you are inviting
the pre-darwinian world all of the
things
that existed in that pre-darwinian world
the belief in inherent superiority that
was not challenged by science that's the
world you're inviting back yes and the
fact that it would happen at nature
right to have the journal nature human
behavior take up arms against the
darwinian study of human behavior is
mind-blowing it's mind-blowing
two last little little quotes from this
again this is the op-ed published in
nature human behavior this week
explaining why science is off
that's not their understanding of what
they've done but
uh gender identity an individual's
conception of self as being a man woman
masculine feminine non-binary ambivalent
etc based in part on physical
psychological and social factors
oh wait that was a definition that
wasn't a complete sense so that's why
that read that way it is the internal
experience of a gender role there was a
broad range of range of gender
identities including but not limited to
you ready oh yeah okay
there's a broad range of gender
identities including but unlimited two
transgender gender queer gender fluid
non-binary gender variant genderless
agender non-gender bigender trans man
trans woman trans masculine trans
feminine and cisgender
holy
and then then two paragraphs down they
say researchers are encouraged to
promote equality between men and women
in their academic research which by
nature should be granted on the
recognition of merit competences and
creativity regardless of any other
personal attributes orientation
well if they're going to divide the
spoils between men and women where does
that leave the gender fluid people i
don't know or the agenda or the
non-gender or the genderqueer or the
or the envies
oh my i mean i'm actually glad that's in
there because
the language beforehand if you don't
know how science is supposed to work and
what they're actually saying and what it
would do to actual science right it's a
little subtle it's a little that's what
we're here we're trying to reveal it as
not being subtle but yeah you could have
am i misreading this uh
response until you get to that business
and then it's like oh i get it this is
just some sort of ideological polemic
and this is no longer a scientific
journal get it you captured it yep um
enjoy it
enjoy it until you bring it to the
ground which you're in the process of
doing yeah exactly yeah let's let's take
let's take the functional things in
society take them over
and destroy them
and then look for more things to take
over and destroy but you know what
they're not gonna last forever there's
not an infinite amount of successful
actual systems because you're destroying
them too fast
okay but then
next next phase
we are about to discover what you and i
already suspect which is that our field
doesn't exist in any meaningful form
anymore
because
our field being broadly evolutionary
biology evolutionary biology and biology
human behavior no human behavior
are
is our field
going to come together
and
say that nature human behavior is
effectively no longer a scientific
journal and should not be taken
seriously because that's the obviously
right response here or are they going to
continue to
publish there and put it on their cvs
proudly
and
i don't know what the name for this
behavior is the cowardice that causes
you when somebody is powerful not to
call out their destruction of things
that you consider to be fundamental
but
if that is what happens here then it
will effectively tell you you can safely
ignore this field because
yep they did us a favor they published
that editorial in a place that we can
read it but where else do these beliefs
have an important editorial role what
are they adjusting about what it is
you're reading in the journals right
well and that's why you know that's why
i organized this the way i did we
started with the internet rando and we
went to the scientific american you know
the magazine that is supposed to be
disseminating
a uh comprehensible version of new
science to people who are smart but not
scientifically
precise
i can't think of the right word but like
not professionals within science and
then the scientific journals and it's
like i said like i said up front it the
language sounds different you know these
guys science nature human behavior is
not talking about morphological freedom
yet
but it's all the same it's certainly
opening the door to it it's all the same
stuff it's it's utterly insane across
the board and the fact is
that you don't have to squint very hard
to say actually um
internet rando and the most precious
prestigious scientific journal are
sounding a lot like one another here and
um they're they're all wrong they're
just they're they're pretending that
reality doesn't exist and imagining that
by doing so they will change what
reality is and that's it doesn't work
that way it doesn't work that way yeah
another way to say it is that you have a
um
an ideology
asserting
its conclusions
its baseless conclusions and it is doing
it now it is so powerful that it is
doing it at every level so that if you
are
an internet rando yourself you can go
you know tweet back at it on twitter and
if you're a you know uh
an academic you know who views yourself
as an important part of
uh what makes humanity civilized then
you get your version of it dressed up in
the proper language for that but the
point is there's no difference in the
rigor of that essay versus the internet
rando
they're exactly equivalent in terms of
their utility as uh you know their
insightfulness it's not insight it's the
assertion of an ideological position
dressed up as the conclusion of sober
people thinking carefully about issues
that's exactly right
that's exactly right
so that's reality for you
there are a number of things we've been
going out for a long time already uh
there are a number of other things that
we thought about talking about
i don't know if you want to do that save
that maybe we should save them okay uh
all of them well you know to save all
them yeah let's let's do a little bit
here um i don't know if you want to do
that
unfortunately i wouldn't buy binoculars
to know oh
okay
uh
um and then uh and then i so why don't
you think about that while we talk a
little bit first about tennis okay
um
tennis the us open which is one of the
uh the
the four biggest tennis tournaments
starts on monday
uh most of our listeners i assume don't
care about tennis but it's a it's an
awesome sport and it happens to be one
that my parents both played and i played
a little bit when i was a kid so it was
like it was the one sport that was uh we
whenever the us opened the australian
open the french opener wimbledon which
is the four grand slam tournaments
um we're on
uh we would have done on the television
for those
week and a half two weeks so they were
on and in fact i think my parents went
um
to at least one of one of them one of
the us opens
which is always uh it it overlaps labor
day in uh what is it
let's say flushing meadows but i feel
like that's a race that's a horse race
anyway somewhere in new york
and
uh
novak yokovich
who is
sort of vying along with uh rafael nadal
and roger federer for like you know
which one of these guys is maybe the
best male tennis player ever uh
i don't know if that editorial
permits you to luckily i'm not
submitting this editorial to nature
human behavior that do go on yes do go
on and in fact you know i said males
like well i don't have to say male
because um as uh
we're not gonna go here really but um
if they are the best male tennis player
ever then they are the best tennis
player ever and that's not to say i i
played tennis i haven't played in
forever but uh you know there has been
some extraordinary female tennis women's
tennis
out there but uh
well but
the best male the best male tennis
player is better than the best female
tennis player sorry end of story done
for now
oh
well if you think about it
all right suppose let's just
hypothetically speak okay here we go the
best male tennis player uh
is uh you know
larry jimbo you know in some
hypothetical future situation
and uh
suppose he becomes nadine
instead of larry
now he can be the best female tennis
player and the he will now be able to
beat
the best male tennis player whoever it
was that he
had initially well in your ridiculous
scenario though um i do think that
although once having gone through
puberty as a male uh you cannot undo the
benefits of that male puberty uh but the
act of
uh hormonal and certainly surgical
transition actually does render you
somewhat less capable so
this is not an argument for anyone who's
decided that they're the sex that
they're not to be able to play with that
sex but it is suggestive that a
top-notch male player who transitioned
might not still be able to beat the
other top-notch male players and of
course it's telling
that
you don't have men at the top of their
game transitioning you have men who are
middling and can't win transitioning and
then beating all the women because
that's what gross men would want to do
like that's not sportsmanlike that's
there's nothing honorable in this but
you know elite male athletes don't
transition right
no i agree and my setup was of course
absurd but my real point is
you are throwing out rules that open the
door to
every conceivable skullduggery and the
inability to say perfectly clear things
is the world threatened by the fact
that the best male tennis player is
going to permanently be better than the
best female tennis player for
morphological reasons among others that
nobody chose
i don't think so but the point is if we
can't even talk about it because
we are going to be forced to embrace the
idea that you know
trans women are women
and therefore a
male tennis player who transitioned to
female and
upended the very clear distinction
between
the quality of play at the top of males
and female tennis
right we're going to lose the ability to
even discuss what is true which is then
going to further open the door for more
madness yeah okay so um but yokovich is
not having trouble because there's
anything about trans anywhere in his
life so far as i'm concerned so not so
far as i know i don't i have no idea um
he's you know he's a he's a character um
you know before kovid
uh i definitely knew people back
especially so federer is 40 and he
didn't play i think in wimbledon this
year because he had knee surgery or
surgeries but he's still like he's not
retired so i mean and all these guys i
think are in their mid late 30s like all
the other two that were talking about
nadal and yokovich and they are all
awesome and many people find you know
watching federer play he's just he's
just beautiful and nadal is powerful and
elegant but it's a different kind of
play and then yokovich's personality
grates on people which shouldn't affect
whether or not you love to watch him
play um but there are there are some
people who sort of you know were rooting
for you know federer to get the most
grand slam titles uh or nadal and um
there are presumably yokovich devotees
but but there were fewer of them because
he's just he's a little bit more of a
brash personality
covet happens
and he becomes one of them
dirty unvaccinated types becomes by
changing nothing about what he was doing
right by saying no thank you i'm healthy
um i'm good and also oh by the way i
don't know if you said this but like oh
by the way elite male athletes
seem to be not doing so well at some
level with these things and um i don't
need one
earlier this year that meant that the
australian open he was already in
country i think uh said actually you're
not you're not allowed to play we're
deporting you or we're taking away your
visa or whatever day i think they locked
them up briefly they quarantined him
even though there was no evidence of his
being sick and then they and then they
kicked him out and this is you know
they're i think i think he and the doll
and federer are all like neck and neck
for the number of grand slam titles
they'll get and okay that was one that
he just had no access to
and now
uh the us isn't allowing him to come
play in the u.s open even though
finally some of the stupid narrative
around covered vaccines is unraveling
and they're going to be unvaccinated
people in the stands watching and
vaccinated people
at least citizens can freely come and go
from the u.s
and the president of the country who is
presumably ultimately responsible for
this decision is quadruple vacs and has
been on pax slovak and all of the best
best best stuff and he's gotten covered
twice because that's how protective
these insane so-called treatments are
and so what is this who is this
protecting
so unfortunately you know if what this
results in is nadal
awesome amazing athlete that he is ends
up with the most grand slam titles of of
any man there's forever ever ever an
asterisk after his name it's not his
fault it's not yokovich's fault it's not
because yokovich not taking one of these
stupid treatments into his arm
is not responsible for this arbitrary
authoritarian decision of supposedly
democratic governments
yeah
i think it's even worse there is a way
in which
there has been a fervor to
[Music]
transfect
people with these agents
that has
too many of us suggested a desire to do
away with anyone
against whom to
compare the health of people who have
had these treatments the control group
is small right eliminating the control
group has has been
one of very few obvious explanations for
the level of fervor for reaching
everybody
and in this case
i hate to say this but the people who
are playing in these tournaments
apparently did
get transfected and given the nature of
the danger especially of the mrna
versions of these transfection agents
it is not impossible
that there would be some subclinical
damage in
some or depending on the pharmakineticus
of these things
multiple and so the question is if
you're going to prevent the pattern from
being provable
again you have to intervene somewhere
else it's rather a lot like
nature human behavior
taking up arms against the idea that
something might be better than something
else in the realm of humans you know you
don't very well want tennis players free
not to take these treatments and then to
see a competition an athletic
competition between people who did and
people who didn't you might be you know
if you had enough variation you might
actually be able to see something and
um you know i hate living in that world
but
given given the we didn't create it
we didn't create it and what's more
our
worst fears about
what was causing the conversation to go
the way that it did as these things were
actively being pushed i mean they're
still being pushed weirdly but
as they were so actively being pushed
you know we now know that there was an
army of people hired to shape
conversation online
right these were paid shills we
suspected there were paid shills but we
now just this is just a simple fact and
so in any case
i do think we have to worry about things
as troubling as are they trying to deny
us the evidence that would become
apparent if we were simply able to go
from here and watch the world
unfold the way it would and be able to
compare people who made different
decisions and just see what happened to
them
there shall be no comparison or
investigation or testing of hypotheses
that we find
unsavory
right exactly and this is unsavory for a
different reason this is unsavory for
you know
pharma capture corruption reasons
but
and just you know just to be clear again
this hypothesis sounds
plausible
by many rubrics but promoting a
hypothesis
proposing a hypothesis
is not saying i believe that thing is
true
proposing hypotheses is what scientists
do it's what we do we therefore in
seeing
a pattern and making an observation it
is our job to come up with all of the
possible explanations for why that
pattern or that observation might exist
it is our job to come up with all of
them if this hypothesis wasn't being
proposed here given that it is a
possibility that would be an indication
that something is awry right so every
time a hypothesis is proposed and some
freaking internet rando says aha
conspiracy theorist
that is a demonstration that that
internet rando like most people
apparently don't know what science is or
how it's done right the proposing of a
hypothesis is necessary to the doing of
science they may not even be a random
that's what we now know they may be
posing as a rando
or or
or they might not be posing as a random
there are a lot of people who are not
randos on the internet
making crazy claims about look at all
these conspiracy theorists out there
when they really ought to know better
that actually proposing hypotheses is
what scientists do and shutting down
conversation and shutting down the idea
of what might be possible is
what
crazy people who want the end of
democracy do
yeah i mean and
you know i'm i'm proud that we coined
the term medically woke because the
point is we are now able to see
out in broad daylight that this is just
a different version of the
authoritarianism with a different target
right it's the same toolkit right you
will not be able to say these things uh
if we find you even thinking them
terrible things will happen to you so
don't think them yeah and you know in
this case it's it's a physiological
topic rather than a moral one but
um
but in any case i did also want to point
out though you know
i don't follow tennis
i've of course
what little i've encountered it i have
certainly heard you know the assertions
that uh
uh djokovic is uh
you know
unlikable or something along these lines
i now
feel very differently about this right
my sense is oh he's disagreeable right
that's disagreeable and he has done
something important here he's become
he's not only a historical figure in
tennis he is now actually a historical
figure for taking a stand in this
context where um
where others have not
and you know yeah i do feel bad that
you know nadal for example if he you
know
achieves the
maximum grand slam wins uh will have the
asterisk but that that is a tiny tiny
price compared to having somebody in a
different milieu where we haven't seen a
lot of courage on this front stand up
and say actually i will i will accept
the cost to my
my historical significance in tennis to
do what i believe is the right thing
here in terms of my health right and
many more people should be making
um that that decision indeed
that's right
are we there or do you want to pick up
one of these other ones no i think i
think we're probably there i i guess um
i did want to say one last thing which
is that the problem
here is that now
uh
one has to have one of two views about
what's going on in tennis right other
either is it yokovich yokovich either
yokovich is a troublemaker who you know
isn't doing his part to protect people
from covid by getting his vaccination
and he's being punished by you know the
powers that be because we what we need
is compliance or he's a hero
who is standing up to those powers in
spite of the fact
that it may cost him a piece of his
legacy in tennis and i would just point
out that you know it is odd that they
have turned tennis into a team sport
it's
oh yes yeah yeah it's it's a very
troubling phenomenon but increasingly i
think we just need to look at this um oh
and actually there's another example of
this yeah out today i don't know if you
uh encountered it did you see the story
about um the mar-a-lago
search it did not well i mean
i mean i i know that that happened right
you're talking about that's the first
time today okay yes uh in the new york
times uh at the very least
the
strong implication emerged
uh it's a two-part implication
the implication is that trump this is as
reported in the new york times yes okay
that the motor the uh warrant was
apparently in part motivated by
this is the claim of the new york times
i am saying one way or the other
the claim
is that trump took documents that
contained
information about uh
confidential informants to our
intelligence apparatus and separately
that confidential informants to our
intelligence apparatus have been uh
killed compromised or captured at an
anomalous rate
since trump left office something
something something something something
yeah this is a pattern that has been
noticed in intelligent circles um why
are they being compromised at an
anomalous rate
the assertion that trump took documents
that contains relevant information and
they therefore connect the dot's
implication
is that uh
he may have handed that information over
to people that's getting these people
killed now i want to point something out
about this
somebody
is engaged in treason
could be trump
but that seems really unlikely here
right because it's obvious treason to
hand over information on confidential
informants that are important to the u.s
u.s intelligence apparatus if informants
are truly being compromised killed
whatever etc uh at an anomalous rate if
it truly is anomalous yeah then a breach
has happened and so wherever that breach
was that was a treasonous breach no no
no no we've got two candidates here one
candidate is trump and the extraordinary
idea that a president would have left
office taken those documents hand them
over to people knowing that that would
result in things happening to those
informants in the field right that would
have just motive here that would
obviously be together okay
if he had the motive okay right i don't
i i do put this past trump i would not
imagine him leaving office right
especially hoping to return to office
compromising
american informants abroad so
either he did that which the new york
times certainly wants us to wonder about
or the new york someone else didn't know
or the new yorker
office but or the new york times is
engaged in treason and alleging so
that's the point
if you are a journalistic establishment
that on the basis of
extremely weak circumstantial evidence
is going to raise this allegation about
a former president
right
you are engaged in a betrayal of the
nation at an extreme level i i would
have to read the article so you haven't
even shown me the article here
so let's just at least put it up so
people know what we're talking about
i sent you a screenshot oh you did
no maybe it's not worth it he's gonna
have to go find it
from your description of what's in the
article i don't have a clear enough
understanding of
what you know what has been seen of what
the justification for the
missing all the right legal words here
but of the of the raid the raid yeah um
you know if if if there's a document
that is in the public domain or that the
new york times has shared the relevant
parts of that that's i can't that's not
i can't make sense of that
there's a screenshot of a title of an
article on a screen
you are claiming something that seems to
me
maybe but i i haven't heard anything yet
that that convinces me of that well i
mean i i think you uh you can certainly
say assuming the following is either the
new york times came out with evidence
today that trump compromised informants
to the american intelligence
establishment in a way that got them or
likely got them killed either they
present that evidence or if they do not
present that evidence then alleging such
such a thing or placing those dots so
that they will be connected about a
former president without that evidence
is well how would it so if if if that
which again you you just you threw this
at me i've never heard of this before
like two minutes ago five minutes ago
something but even even if the latter
what they're doing is egregious against
a former president but is that treason i
believe so there so the problem is that
this is obviously somebody who's
eligible to be re-elected today
but you know so slant slandering
citizens is not treason
slandering
former presidents who are eligible to be
re-elected
i believe is tantamount to it if it is
not based on evidence i mean if if it's
slander i
i just don't have any of the information
in front of me all right so you know
i've said what i have to say here i'm
not i'm not convinced but i don't know
like
you can show me what you've seen and
then perhaps perhaps we can come back to
it or hopefully not
or
uh or perhaps the new york times will um
put its
foot more clearly in its mouth
well i will say you don't have to
respond to it but i will say
their uh
journalistic ethics would require the
new york times to behave very very
carefully in light of this possibility
and what they have what possibility
the possibility that a former president
has compromised
confidential informants of the us
intelligence apparatus in such a way
that has gotten them killed
were that possible the right
journalistic thing to do
would be to go very slow not put it into
public attempt to find that information
rather than report on it willy-nilly
right connecting those dots or placing
those dots so that they will be
connected
is
um
[Music]
a political act
a political act in a highly charged
context and this wasn't in the opinion
pages this is in the news section
yeah and that i mean that's that's
something we haven't really talked about
um
the nature human behavior op-ed that we
spent so much time talking about today
is labeled an op-ed but an op-ed at
nature
is so a scientific journal is different
from a newspaper in a lot of ways right
a newspaper has a news team and it's
separate from its editorial team and the
editorial team
both writes some editorial pieces but
also solicits editorials from
from other people
and the news team is separate there's
like a firewall between them right and
that is as it needs to be because the
editorial pages of the newspaper doesn't
make the newspaper the news is over in
the news part whereas a scientific
journal like nature human behavior has
has scientific papers in it and it also
has editorials sometimes and news
sometimes but it's all the same people
there is no expectation of firewall
there is no presumption of our
expectation of firewall so it's the
editors
who are doing the first pass on the
scientific papers that come in do i just
reject out of hand do i send to peer
review do you know and if peer review
which peer reviewers do i send it to
it's the same editors who wrote this
op-ed so there's no firewall there and i
mean this this actually is i think
important too in terms of like what what
are we seeing in terms of the breakdown
of
our institutions and our organizations
scientific journals and newspapers
aren't the same they aren't structured
in the same way you can't have the same
expectations of them but one thing that
is true is
if this article that you're talking
about that i've you know barely seen a
headline for was published in the new
york times in the opinion pages
they can do whatever they want
but the standards are different when
they are publishing it
in the news division and well
i mean there are three tiers you've got
the news division you've got a new york
times uh editorial and then you've got
op-eds by columbus and the standards are
would be different for all of those well
but there's two divisions the the
op-eds written by the editorial staff at
the new york times and the op-eds
written by out people from the outside
which are solicited by the editorial
staff or um or they're you know you can
also like
cold call is not the right word but you
can you also submit and then maybe you
can accept maybe you don't
but that's all sort of in-house in the
editorial wing and then the news wing is
different
yeah um i agree i just uh the the
statement that they can do whatever they
want is obviously too strong because
it's
it's a little too strong but
under the auspices of this is our
opinion
they're allowed to do a lot more there's
and
part of what you're saying is there's a
news article there's an article that is
purporting to be news that is reporting
the news
all the news that fits that is fit to
print i believe is the new york times
logo or motto rather
and if they reliably
print all the news that fits their
ideology that is fit to print and not
all the news that doesn't fit their
ideology that is fit to print then they
have fallen down on their journalistic
standards and they aren't doing
journalism anymore
right i'm saying something more which is
that if they are attempting to create
the impression that a former president
has committed treason and it is not
based on
uh actual evidence it is based on the
juxtaposition of
facts that
do not have a relationship to each other
right then
what is it to allege
treason or to create the impression of
treason artificially by juxtaposing
those objects in your you know news
pages
right and my point is
um
that that is an egregious breach in the
context especially of a person who is
eligible uh to run for office that that
is uh
an exotic intervention into a political
discussion
um masquerading as an evidentiary claim
all right
anything else i think that's it
okay
well we are going to do a q a as we do
most weeks uh we will take about a 15
minute break and come back you can ask
questions at darkhorseadmissions.com
you can also if you want a
a longer and more intimate q a with us
uh tomorrow where we actually can engage
the chat you can find that by going to
my patreon and joining there
and brett also has a couple of
conversations coming up on his patreon
we encourage you to join us there
you can if you have any logistical
questions like
um hey i've got a card i want to send
them which we do we get some cool mail
you can either go to either websites and
find an address or email
darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
for
uh for logistical questions but it's
darkhorseammissions.com for the
questions for the q a
lots else to say but maybe we'll sign
off with be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]
you